the bachelor in paradise two-part season  finale is coming et was on set in Mexico  just before it was taped right after  fantasy suites to find out who was  headed towards an engagement who do you  think really will make it out of this  and be together uh obviously Carlene hi  and it seems like Evan was ready to pop  the question to Carly I want to marry  that girl for sure I could see a life  with her forever  and she's amazing every night we're  having dinner right over there and just  like four hours we'll just talk about  stuff and those beautiful moments that  you know we'll never forget and I've  really built a foundation for us I've  always wanted an epic love story and  this this really has been an epic love  story there's nothing better in the  world than hearing her laugh it's so  weird but I definitely think we're  feeling something that's bigger than I  felt I think probably ever the season  finale airs Monday and Tuesday night on  ABC  you